[Musique]
ch
drôle les gens oublient tu redécouvre
la et si je chante l'amour ou bien
n'importe quoi qu'importe le sujet les
gens disent de
moi
pour
a aussi le B
cœur et la de rétro avec ses WAP de twi
dans ma tête
ch la venir
pass
changer les Ch 14 hésit le regard
enchanté disif c'est
unou c'est un
r quelle brutalité dans ces
fant si je bois dans un Baris
le TR qui gr une bag
a
pas
je traverse la rue en négligeant le bras
du f pr du feu les
gens il n'a aucun respect pour
lesardens la
si je mange en gourm dans un de Cho
qu'importe ma tenue
les
ma les intellectuel journalistes é de ma
musique
pour dans le contexte
actuelution
saxuelle de fr me teur me font de grands
sourir je
reste ah je
suis je je pas où je veux à l'instant où
je
veux r r
r
[Musique]
R